[Music]
it's this week we've got felony proposal
fried chicken phone and shadowboxing
beatdown takeaways let's start with a
shadowbox beatdown because how did your
shadow look your ass hush you know that
idiot she's going to save the best for
last
yes you [ __ ] the robbery story there's
this man that lives in Oklahoma his name
is Brandon they got a lot of tornadoes
in Oklahoma they random so Brendan was
with his family on 4th of July they were
celebrating celebrating his birthday and
just turned 35 years old when police
arrived to arrest him on his six felony
warrants that he had while he was being
arrested he had a request awful fool
what do you think well because he said
the title so I guess definitely proposed
exactly how romantic
not you guys would forget was wholly
regard absolutely forgot so romantic
yes he proposed I know I'm going to jail
for life but let me do something I need
to do this and the stupid lady was like
of course of the wife will you pay me
yes sir le'andria's okay said yes good
like that
of course I'm asked you saw then that he
had to ring ready and all that yeah so
he was huge handcuffed to the champion
his back when he asked officers can I
propose I get the ring out to propose to
my girl they pepper spray them that's
lamb shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ]
there was a family member nearby which I
believe it was his mom or someone and
she was like can I get the ring out of
his pocket oh my god yes so then the
police officer is very nice enough to
move his handcuffs
to the front so he could put the ring on
girl I thought he just like pops it up
behind I'm Cornish Tito's eyes baby will
you wearing something is a quick clip of
the body cam footage the proposal I got
to be honest I thought all that was
going to end with and then a tornado hit
him good just because he said us like it
was neither thank you my subtle tornado
visas well question yes was he already
planning to
pose that day but he just so happened to
be served that day probably it seems
like that so it's coincidental
like he was like planning this whole
thing out and then the cops came and he
was like oh man insanity and just
bothering only he was planning to but he
didn't get to do it but he had the ring
on him
so with this body cam footage but nobody
else my family nobody not it was
reporter how romantic recorded with
their mom I'm not going to show you that
video it's like [ __ ] you very much
i'ma show you the body campus this
ghetto Chronicle is so nice oh my god so
what's next in this ghetto saga to all
my birthday and the same day he planned
to pop the question to his girl oh yeah
it was the same day we captured the
moment before they took him to jail when
she got down on one knee to propose and
she said yes why why oh so fourth of
July stop even move and make sense
through the clothes yeah body so he
could put the ring on her finger himself
I was like I never seen so many mixed
blood Crips in my life but what the July
saw because they all are like astral
pops oh you went to jail a happy man so
the next days is your fiancee building
out oh oh oh my god Carol Chronicles
indeed and you put a cop posted on
Facebook she what are the photos which
not every day you get asked to let a
marriage proposal happen after taking an
arrest on the soon-to-be groom but it
happened video to come muskeg you these
cops are suckers for love
that's so funny cuz if I was there and
I'll be like why it like nah [ __ ] that
you're going to jail dude I don't give a
[ __ ]
uh you can know when you get billed out
I was like do what you get with the
fondue like you know got no rights
[ __ ] least at the moment you get
arrested you pretty much lose all your
right but everyone here agreed and
thought this would be a great idea and
thought it would be it's so romantic
like the wife of Grameen the the
bride-to-be or whoever what do you call
that a fiance yeah who do you call that
she agreed all the cops agreed everyone
just stopped and said let's do it what
all what is his crime so any Queens all
the national enquirer are - felon
possession of a controlled substance and
failure to appear in court among others
oh those are normal ones yeah he's just
a regular guy not mostly just a normal
guy no I mean okay so like yeah yes
nothing normal like crime lad guys armed
robbery maybe a little bit of cool the
country possession you know maybe
burglary maybe cars that you're getting
to be the yeah this guy just keeps
desperate for money it's lady crimes is
their possession crimes possession of
firearm possession of drugs he didn't go
out and do something like a pencil arey
Clinton exactly this another lady crimes
he didn't show up in court he's too
[ __ ] lazy to wake up right he didn't
bust nuts on a stop right is that way
might be illegal what you're on was
really good like assault charge or
robbery charge and that's a devi lady
crimes Laden drive his car through a
building he's an honorable man yeah he
wants things but he's too lazy to ghin
yeah like if he auditioned for the Fast
& Furious crew oh don't be like we're
all criminals but we're not lazy
criminal yeah yeah because they drive
their cars through buildings and stuff
that it makes Excel would sake he
doesn't belong in any world he's like
right in between
he was scallywag no no the 1960s in
college again yeah in here when he
picked his nose what if it's not a
[ __ ] leprechaun that's tickling his
nose another scallywag oh my that is a
marriage thing that I why no he has
leprechauns in his nose because it's
tickling him yeah so he doesn't have a
booger I don't pick my nose I scratch
he furiously digs in his nose as if it's
[ __ ] like did something wrong like
offended his mom yeah
like he any uses to think yeah that's my
outer conductor because you're pushing
your other hand out at the same time no
it's scratching you can't win any
arguments a lot of things he doesn't
agree watching an ass crack watching his
face his eyes angry Oh Artu first
version of this way his are like okay no
fair enough - as well I am yeah I'm bad
with that you have you ever try to like
like clean your bathtub with like a
toothbrush is what it looks like yeah
that'd mean would you see the center's
just plastic yep sorry nice story
KFC Kentucky Fried Chicken yes it's not
that bad
hater I love all fried chicken to be
honest Church's Chicken and Popeyes
churches is delicious but ill above all
fat chicken and of course louisiana
fried chicken as well louisiana fried
chicken is like the best like i'm so
biased i dont consider their messiah
huh chain chain though they're not a
chain chain chain chain chain oh why is
fried chicken so cool i mean it's like
really good like it's so good to like oh
man i've someone told me right now
there's a fresh [ __ ] piece of fried
chicken ready for me all I got to do is
punch this grandma in the face and
knocked adventures out her mouth if no
one could know that it was me I [ __ ]
do it dude farts largest bomb this way
it's awful oh my chicken Becky you don't
you don't need to worry about that with
this story because this isn't really
talking about the actual chicken so in
order for them to celebrate their thirty
years since they opened in China what
thirty years in China thirty years in
China [ __ ] they are celebrating by
releasing these limited-edition
smartphone what don't do that to me -
ding Toronto final 10 counting
it's actually in simplified why is there
an ice cream cone on the case
ice cream good it is something about 30
years a bone I can read know one thing
don't so from that point on it's on
Wisconsin yen and it is gene in which is
like to commemorate and it's something
cell phone down so the thirtieth your
Chinese is good something like that it's
actually it's not an ice cream cone it's
the kernel oh that's [ __ ] old [ __ ]
so that's on the phone that's not like a
case they couldn't have just made a case
they were like let's make no more they
made an entire time I can read that it's
seven was very cheap Colonel Sanders is
so interesting if you took away his
smile he just looks like a sexual
predator yeah he does he just look like
a Chinese grandpa can you talk to if I
see champ
I mean campaign was like one of the
first things that I teach in in
Indonesia and here and I was like oh I
recognize this place
yeah because it was like everywhere but
you know when you eat it there you get
it with rice and you get it with like
hot sauce alright so when I came here
other brother hey chase what are we
eating this or the biscuit you know what
I don't like about chasing Lou I don't
like my fancy let us know what do you go
there for for crunchy or original I
don't mean Ron's okay this is what it is
I don't go that for anything cuz I got
food poisoning from there so I have the
mental block well I can't imagine you
ever masturbating or getting food
poisoning
Wow I'll show you food poisoning because
I'll keep on track I've ever had one
yeah you'll do both at the same time
until you like the [ __ ] sounds you
can't make both of that weight away and
I mean that is they have so they're
extra crispy chicken is nowhere near as
crispy as just church's regular [ __ ]
true which is [ __ ] annoying well why
why does their [ __ ] get soggy after like
a few minutes yeah it's [ __ ] stupid
from what I remember when I was like 14
hmm no they're they're extra crispy is
not but I just gotta get it fresh but
it's nowhere near a church as though
yeah purchase crunch is like exactly
I've never had I've never had purchased
chicken come out to songs oh I like it
now I'm going to show you guys but you
know what though what I do like about
them is they have what is it twenty six
verbs and spices
or how many no I don't get it they have
many many earth get the normal straight
original give me some hot sauce on there
done and some right the original advice
on you dude that shit's like that fool
and fried chicken midi under a Church's
Chicken no and their hot sauce
I love charges hot sauce to octane what
the [ __ ] you're a [ __ ] that's what your
food anyway and their [ __ ] honey
biscuits are [ __ ] delicious get
churches - I'll give it Tommy is taking
the Church's Chicken out those you
biscuits how about Popeyes though I like
Popeye Popeye is good top writers like
the it's the baseline
I still like KFC though I still like
original and I still like I do too I
don't want to hear this story
oh yeah yeah fried chicken from any
brand to a potluck ha ha there's no
[ __ ] story is just a [ __ ] phone I
can't be with a bundle you know why
don't you you know you know what your
year anniversary way way hon they're
giving it away it's good as assassin
ingenious so they aren't giving them
away he goes ok then why the [ __ ] would
anyone want to buy that [ __ ] finish
[ __ ] fine over one hundred and sixty
two dollars or 1099 you on my show you
guys a quick lift of their advertisement
like promoting this this goodbye
cellphones out of KFC a China
why's it all sexual they got Kenny G to
do the soundtrack and then it Queen to
the kids are you serious play music at
the same key with you can control the
speakers they're like a jock like so it
comes with this program in the phone
where you can go to a cave the
restaurant and then you can fit your
phone like a jukebox begins like request
up to play a song in the story you're in
oh they are just saying that they're
releasing these phones to celebrate it
and there's a limited edition so thank
God some nice color you know what's a
really cool phone though that Samsung
Galaxy s8 these gopis [ __ ] I'm bucks
which no I don't want to see a green
bubble but it's um I gotta support your
own Koreans for I have you touch the
phone you'll understand okay cuz I don't
I'm not a big Samsung fan I've had like
two or three years switching I might
just because it's your phone's not going
to work your laptop little work you're
connected to everything it's so
beautiful a lot you cannot laureate have
two phones
it's just give you like those Japanese
and so beautiful though you have no idea
it's [ __ ] awesome still a
choreographed reversal you know that I'm
not done getting my fried chicken talked
out you don't even you only wrote so my
story is it's a shadow but what about
three losers hey you guys gonna like it
yeah oh here we go oh he broke his leg
damn dude that invisible man [ __ ] the
love
that wherever that goes was they know
how to fight oh he tore something in his
way I want to fight this guy because he
beat himself up Oh
how does he did he punch up some of the
face nah nah he swung so hard that he
didn't even put his foot down nice it
looked like this he [ __ ] swung her so
hard
I was thinking yeah yet his right leg
behind him and we got long for a hook
with his right arm is leg went around it
yeah my god sucks why did you tear so
this video was uploaded by Brennan
recorded it and his friends were
laughing - what a good friend but I'm
really do you laugh and then you find
out though he go home could you laughs
honey upload the video everybody but
there was no Oh or anything like that it
was hahaha I think they realized how
badly I wouldn't have either I would
have been tears laughing dude I probably
would've walked up and spit on his face
what the hell yes I his name is Ryan and
the only thing that we know is that he
broke his like we don't know how or like
where exactly or just how strong it's
his right fist to walk him around that
hard he must be an amazing amazing
fighter because that's how the momentum
was that powerful it snapped his leg off
that's another kind of weight
I just think that he's so strong that
his body can't even control the amount
of strenght that comes out of him to do
that
I feel like he's just so uncoordinated
that we thought it was going on runways
yet his legs didn't really listen and
just stayed there and that's how that's
what happened I was trying to give some
credit but never mind I thought it was
like a teenager breathe twenty four you
can be any age this is guy behavior
that's true I've never seen anyone beat
themselves up this guy though what are
you saying
I can't make it out what they subscriber
hi he was fighting an invisible opponent
yeah that was kind of trying to division
one opponent once - yeah um which I like
- like damn he got Anderson Silva dude
oh by a [ __ ] ghost dude that's so
crazy how strong he is man
hey guys would you think of that video I
know you loved it so make sure to hit
that like button to watch more videos
check it out up here
[Music]